good morning John it is May the 6th the
day after my awesome birthday thank you
everyone for my awesome birthday I got a
Jane hat I also got an anglerfish hat
it's got an anglerfish thing up there
basically here's how my birthday when I
slept in and then I got up and I checked
Twitter and I discovered that Helen Hunt
had tweeted at me that she had seen my
videos and also that the restraining
order she's sending me is decorated with
little flowers and smiling cakes then I
watched Henry being adorable and then I
chatted with you for a while and then I
saw lots of amazing videos from
nerdfighteria Thank You nerdfighteria
you're so nice then I went and I checked
my mail and in my mail was a letter from
the IRS telling me that I didn't pay
enough taxes in 2009 so I owe them a lot
of money and I don't know whether to
believe them are not peace thought I
paid the right amount in taxes in 2009
so that wasn't my favorite part of my
birthday but then that X guy came and he
had a giant box and that giant box was
full of all the amazing things that
nerdfighters got for me like my Jane hat
and this taco dinner cake also this
chubby little hangry and cutie they
think you got corn dogs in a guitar do
you have to be a duct tape wallet I need
knitted rocket and also a little magnet
with nerdfighter hands basically all
kinds of awesome stuff so many words I
just made him hump my face that is a
weird do you have to be a pop-up this is
an entire deck of playing cards made out
of duct tape which is just insane it
came in a box made of duct tape you
could make anything from donkeys so
amazing card so amazing card what does
it look like much on the outside but on
the inside it's amazing what the Freak
I'm on are you in a good with Masha
bondage button there's a companion cube
pinata I'm hitting it with a lightsaber
hard portal face things Helen haunted my
birthday cake she's got corndogs toward
me and then probably the best birthday
card not of my birthday but of all time
humpy Hank birthday card and you can
make him go different speeds
yeah and fast or check this out you can
make him hump different things humping
Minecraft no I don't want to hump
minecraft today I want a hump a peep up
the pinyon I'm gonna a but a corn dog
hump the card dog oh good from noxee
thank you knock see also in among all
those birthday cards giant wad of cash
and $5 in an origami star oh that's just
amazing I've never seen this before
and I like it I'm gonna make it into a
Christmas ornament but I'm going to
donate five other different dollars to
charity for this person if I didn't get
your cards yet uh they are still sending
me more from Ohio I'm very excited to
get them and thank you to Catherine of
course she got me a membership to the
they may be Giants fan club which I
can't believe I haven't had yet so we
thank you
finally to John for being great brother
I will see you on Monday
and screen time hello nerdfighters after
a severe punishment drought we now are
understanding what that means to when it
rains it pours because now you have one
punishment for John not putting a video
up on Wednesday and you have two
punishments for getting a Helen Hunt to
see the Helen Hunt video that's three
punishments two for John and one for me
I'm not flicking you off that's the this
one it's the not flicky offi one so we
need lots of good punishment ideas down
there is where you put punishment ideas
in the comments to this video we're
going to be reading them please go
through all so if you have time and
thumb up ones that you like so that they
will pop out and we're looking forward
to having you punished no or not dftba
and goodbye